this man spreads hate against Russians
across the city of Tbilisi but as fast
as he can graffiti the city paints over
it with equal speed he wants all the
Russians out of Georgia and Russia out
of Ukraine the war between Russia and
Georgia 14 years ago still stirs strong
feelings and similarities between that
and the war in Ukraine are common here
we were out here Putin huala here that
Russia is and occupier and terrorist
State and on this wall this is our
message to the citizens of Russia that
Russians you are not home here
he is part of a collective of activists
who are becoming increasingly vocal and
angry over the influx of tens of
thousands of Russians who have arrived
since President Vladimir Putin announced
a partial mobilization of men to fight
in Ukraine
Nick represents the more extreme almost
xenophobic end of anti-russian sentiment
however you don't have to travel very
far to find people who are equally
concerned they're worried about Rising
rents in their neighborhoods they're
also worried about those same
neighborhoods being swamped
bucktang is a digital artist who
reversions traditional Georgian
historical figures into futuristic
digital art he's also concerned that
local people could be squeezed out
I think that in every country we should
have tourism but now there are more
Russian tourists than normal they aren't
provoking us and that's fine but when
they do it becomes an issue 50 of
Russians seem okay most of them I don't
like
Russians in Tbilisi are also feeling the
change in Attitude
some of the young people have an
aggressive attitude they say why are you
coming here I think people under 25
mainly but pensioners also say we are
making prices go up and they say Putin
will make us join Russia
one of the first things many people do
when reaching a new place is get a local
phone number and outside the phone shop
these Russians are sharing their
knowledge of where to live and the
basics of moving to a new place but with
official statistics of around 9 000
people arriving every day the tide of
sentiment against them seems to be
rising as quickly as the numbers
crossing the border Imran Khan Al
Jazeera tablisi